hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay it's dark
it's dank and by all accounts it's kind
of creepy I kind of like it they just
gave me okay
courtesy shower
I like it they they just gave me a
flashlight a feelin kind of gives me
some help because what made amnesia
scary is the fact that you couldn't do
anything at all whoa hey ha ha ha oh god
I don't know if any of you saw that but
there was a friggin shadow on a wall
the lighting was just way way better is
that a sandal
I'll flip it floppy so is that oh don't
tell me with that
okay oh no not event I don't care
refract Network go away what do I have
to go towards it okay look
they
Oh Oh what's up with that guy what
happened are you all right ma why are
you helping me
if tideland finding more people will die
including bacon not if you fall in my
words I don't like this you don't have
to like it
just hurry before you get locked in you
shut up you under whatever what do I
gotta beat this there we go okay I do it
okay I want to go that way but there's
freaking fall oh here we go
yeah we can rap the wall
oh he's an engineer of course he does
I guess oh I got a contagious module hey
haha heard that hey buddy whoa in it
I said whoa there we go anymore
ooh this body
look at why
on that pack
man tactical
a lot of blood
now it's good as a chair but I guess it
I don't need it I got help well I guess
I could I can fit one more bar whatever
you say I'll trust your wisdom game
hello
well don't trust ah what the hell what
the hell what the hell what the hell
there you are I see you home yeah got
him here
chew on this stuff one more ah yay
you gonna get that back please please
please come out of it about of goopy
speery duties what's this
take a shelf Oh what that stuff slow ha
ha
got you I didn't get you high and then
smash your body eyes against hunger ah
here were some doodads ok down there
oh that's where I was
mmm
I'm Way too brave for this game
no don't trust you Dutchess uh-huh stomp
stomp it stomp pick up whoa God just
know don't trust you
sure we'll share yeah yeah yeah serve me
well now go away
who's that harm
okay
yeah maybe don't know if I trust you
I'll be with you when I'm good and ready
I'm right here what are you talking
about whoa I saw legs here
what the hell monster no oh hello what
the hell going on there I shut up don't
judge me collecting items ah don't you
know this scavenging is a very important
part of this game
Oh fine
jeez such a wuss oh you oh yeah whatever
god I'm a help calm down tissue laser a
plasma cutter laser cutter oh come on
Isaac yeah engineer
I'm trying
well here we go can it still yep there
we go
ask you to cut no don't dodge me do well
fo heavy Wang yeah I just like slap that
on my flashlight a badass a my mom small
anyway here we go ha ha enemies will
brutalize me haha I'm so great
Oh seems like now every time I stop at
enemy it gives me some items which well
didn't kill you to hell ah move yeah
what the hell
super strong one
I want to waste the ammo playing on a
harder difficulty I'm willing to bet
that I need all the fine fine
BAM got all of you give me a ride up
cool
ah back to the small inventory again
same layout I like film familiarity
Isaac its Dana you hello Dana
the creatures to stop them hahaha I've
had a lot of practice just try to stay
in one piece oh good one Shana or Dana
whatever your name is you're gonna be
named Jenny I'm calling you Jin okay hey
open
okay those up no dog trust you don't
trust ya oh yeah I think you're angry
I like stopping stopping away better
instead of just whoa oh it's actually
kind of quick there we go
anything behind them can't get that high
maybe that maybe if I got guy thing on
yes nope who's that hello intensive-care
way to Gary okay
ah fire
I got startled by a little [ __ ] Wow Oh
God thoughts awesome okay I'm officially
freaking myself out for nothing
crash can
oh look nice little area he's where the
fish
while the fish get turned into super
mutants monster zombies aliens are they
aliens I never really officially found
out what these things were top that ha
ha
brutalized you come from
sounded a lot beefier in Alaska yeah
sort of but a real guttural grunts which
is what what I like in a man I don't
know about you all
huh
why
I like that they're giving him a voice
to speak with now young ah the silent
protagonist works in a lot of situations
but and sometimes you know dialogue
helps not sure it helps with the
immersion but I don't know I have to
play
it's real immersion in a Hargett comes
when you feel like you're in the
situation guiding someone oh I know how
to reload we think I am a noob funny
uh-huh good advice don't trust you still
oh he tucks it in for to us it's a
kinetic response or something kinetic
something I forget the technical term
for that it's like the same thing that
lets in a game lets your foot displace
up and down okay excellent
but again the patients are becoming
agitated and combative combative with us
as a result of a new regimens of memory
erasing drugs they no longer remember
who we are from day to day and must be
convinced to leave their cells
each morning many are so frightened they
require sedation to get the
interrogation chamber to get to the
interrogation chamber totally goof
city's was bitten three times by
patients six who now must be told why he
has a broken jaw okay so they got
patients and they're interrogating them
for what and they're erasing their
memory again for what
Atsuko gotcha really dark like at least
in dense ways one that seems like it was
a lot more ambient lighting now in this
one it seems like the lighting is all
directional and localized which is more
realistic you're sure to constant supply
okay thank you earth go this looks good
Isaac hi
I don't trust that guy we went to hell
he was that the guy from the video it
was okay buddy
are you still alive I didn't even see
how the gun
got chair
I thought I saw some aliens monster
trying to sneak up on me
all right
okay way to go dudes back
Dana your [ __ ] round didn't work
there's a security lockdown I don't
hurry how'd your mission look I don't
need your help
fine yeah well hello I got a chair back
off yeah yeah
actually legitimate light actually
about your arm time on and off the other
to shot the ball womp Oh double well I
lost all advantage I have my mini Oh
goodies bring down god damn oh so good
okay you're right
I do need your help Oh time is your
enemy not me who's tired of him all
right Rick fine so what the hell am I
how did another Necromorph outbreak get
started you're on Tyson station or
you're certain as to the output [ __ ]
time ins Johnny Mac yeah sure blame this
mysterious guy girl I've been
I don't know just for power no yeah
all right I'm out of time for this
episode but thank you all so much for
watching and I will see you in the next
part
bye bye